whoa did you guys see that right there
this is an m1 ipad pro with 8 gigs of
ram
and this one has 16 gigabytes which is
absolutely crazy for a tablet
so today we're gonna put him head to
head and find out
are there any performance differences
when you're using them normally
and then do we get any performance
differences once all that ram
is filled up on the 8 gig since that ram
is shared between the cpu
and the gpu we're seeing a lot of people
being pressured to spend more money
on the 16 gig version which you can only
get
if you buy the one terabyte or two
terabyte models
because they think they need to have it
and me personally i need to figure out
which one of these do i need to
keep so let's go ahead and put these
heads ahead and find out now before i
get into the real world photo and video
editing tests as well as background app
management to see if the a gig will shut
down the apps much more often than 16
i want to go ahead and restart these
machines to clear out everything
and then do a baseline reading let's go
ahead and start these and see if one of
these turns on
faster than the other nope exactly the
same so the ram is completely clear
let's go ahead and open up
geekbench 5. as you can see we have
eight gigs on this side and 16 gigs on
this side
we're gonna go ahead and start out with
a cpu test now personally i'm really
curious to see if we're gonna have any
differences i know sometimes
if you have extra ssd space that ssd
will run faster
and as far as ram i don't really expect
that to be
but who knows we might get surprised and
bam we have our results
and it looks like as far as multi-core
the a gig is actually slightly faster
it's not much of a difference but it is
slightly faster and it's actually
slightly slower in single core
and looking through the detailed tests
pretty much everything is
matching up which is kind of what i
expected
but we will see if these results differ
once these machines
have their ram maxed out now i also want
to go ahead and do
a graphics test all right and it looks
like in this one
there's actually a bigger gap with a 16
gigabyte coming in at about 2
faster still not a huge deal but let's
go ahead and move on to the next test
and that is going to be geekbench
machine learning this is a brand new
test i'm going to check this out right
here
and then afterwards we will start
loading up the system with
maybe some games some other programs
before we do more performance tests
and bam look at that the score is almost
identical going slightly to the 8 gig
model
and this is running with the core ml
back end so let's go ahead and close
that and i'm going to start by just
opening up each one of these apps over
here
that way we can get some different apps
load in the background and these are all
pretty simple ones
let's open up safari and let's open up
maybe five or so
tabs so it's interesting i don't know if
you guys saw a difference there
at the end when i would switch to the
new tab that i just opened in the
background it would be instantly on
where here it actually wouldn't open it
until i clicked on it that was very
weird
so let's go ahead and close that and i'm
going to get into my next test which is
the brand new 3d mark
wildlife i'm going to go into the
unlimited mode to get
a 4k test let's go ahead and get started
here
wow that is a really fast test and
looking at the results the frame rate's
almost identical 109.7 compared to 109.4
so it looks like in that test nothing
has really changed
let's go ahead and open something else
i'm going to run gfx benches
metal and it looks like we have 52.76
compared to 53.1 so slightly faster on
the 8 gig
so far the results are almost identical
as i've been testing this the only thing
that i've actually noticed is that it
seems like the 8 gig
takes a little bit longer to start up
these tests and i'm not sure if that's
because
that's to clear out some ram or who
knows but
we're going to go ahead and push these
to the test even more so
i want to go ahead and open up google
chrome we're going to get some more tabs
here i don't know how you guys are
but me personally i usually have a ton
of tabs open
because i'm not great at closing them on
my tablets or on my phone
so how about we go ahead and do 10 and
what i want to see
like we saw in safari is it going to
actually load up everything in the
background by itself
or is it going to load up once i
actually go into that tab
so let's go ahead and press on both of
these okay it looks like they're both
running the same way and it could be a
difference in chrome
so it doesn't actually load it up until
i press into it
all right those are really quick and
let's go back into safari and i want to
see if those other tabs
remained open all right that is open
there
both are open there try the last one
both are still open all right now what i
want to do is open up
a couple games just to fill up extra ram
in the background and then we're going
to get to photo and video editing i'm
going to start out by opening up
photoshop on both of these we'll go
ahead and open up this high quality
stock file look at all that detail right
there
so far so good and then now oftentimes
i'm also working in lightroom so let's
open that up i have these
50 raw images that have a bunch of
corrections applied they're 42
megapixels
quite large and these are stored locally
on the ipads
so let's go and open them up and see if
there's any difference in responsiveness
so far
no everything is super smooth let's go
ahead and zoom in here
that looks great let's mess with some of
the adjustments
both of them are awesome and with all 50
of these edited
raw images selected and with a bunch of
background apps and games open along
with photoshop
let's go ahead and export all of these
i'm gonna go ahead and export these
to the camera roll and we're gonna start
our timer
and it looks like they are almost done
and the results are
basically identical bam the first one
got done
and the second one bam the difference is
literally
four seconds we have three minutes in
one second compared to
three minutes and five seconds and now
i'm gonna keep
this whole thing open and i'm gonna go
ahead and open up
lumafusion and here i have a 4k
project opened up and this project is
quite difficult i have
a bunch of effects added on to here i
have
color grading effects i have um some
slow motion clips
some that are sped up so i'm gonna go
ahead and pause this here
i'm gonna keep it at 4k we have megabit
per second so we're gonna have a high
quality
video and bam we are going now i gotta
say that these new ipads are insanely
fast with the new m1 they were actually
exporting faster than the m1 macbook air
running lightroom the same exact version
which is crazy
and after this export we're gonna go
ahead and see which applications
remained open so let me go ahead and hit
lap
wow okay so that was almost identical
but the 8 gig model
actually was about 2 seconds faster we
have 57 seconds
compared to 59 seconds for this project
and the last thing i want to do
before we go through all those apps is
run another
geekbench 5 test with all those apps
open in the background all those pro
apps let's go ahead and hit run here all
right we have our result and it looks
like
the score is basically the same as
before except actually this time
the 16 gig is both slightly slower in
the single core
and in the multi-core but it is very
very close
so that is interesting you guys saw all
those tests
the performance didn't really matter
ipad os is very well optimized it's
optimized to be used with two gigabytes
of ram three gigs
four gigs six gigs like on the previous
ipad pros and then now
eight and sixteen but with that said
let's go ahead and see what stayed open
in the background
and what got closed so i'm just going to
go through
we'll swipe through geekbench is open
video editing open we have this file
ready to be saved
wherever we want so that file is just
sitting there
go through back to geekbench there let's
do it this way let's go and open up
photoshop whoa did you guys see that
right there
did you guys notice that the 16 gig
model
closed photoshop there
whereas the 8 gig model kept it open
that is really bizarre all right
so let's go ahead and jump back into
what should we try let's try
um let's try gentian impact
okay open there open there on both
let's try gfx bench open on both
let's do 3d mark open on both
let's do youtube here
okay all right settings opened up right
here
it looks like both of them probably
reloaded just what's on the screen
let's try imovie i have a project right
here
both opened up okay how about pages
same keynote opened up
numbers nothing there clips
looks like both of them reloaded all
right let's do garageband
okay we're still there on both i have to
say ipad os
is so well optimized let's do our apple
store
okay okay there we go i thought this one
was closed actually for a second but
actually
just refresh everything faster than our
8 gig model
let's do let's do geekbench ml
crazy open on both photos
okay it looks like both of them reset or
at least to this
viewer and then the last thing that i'm
interested in is safari
and chrome so let's start out with
safari i was saving that
bam okay same exact thing there next tab
both there get an
ad pop up all right it makes it
difficult last one
both opened up right here the video
stopped and the last one is going to be
chrome because we all know how chrome
runs
at least you know on windows and mac who
knows on ipad but i guess we'll see
three two one bam
okay we don't want to paste there but at
least this
base tab opened up let's carefully
switch to the next one
wow great
that one's awesome no issues
wow so with all of that what is the
final verdict and which version would i
recommend
buying well as you guys saw the
performance is basically the same even
with all those different apps open the
background and then we're doing
crazy photo editing raw files 42
megapixel from a pro camera doing 4k
video editing photoshop open all of that
performance did not matter the 8 gig was
not
any slower at all and then as far as
opening apps
the 8 gig actually did better it kept a
ton of apps open games productivity
everything tabs and it actually kept
photoshop open
as well whereas a 16 gig closed it that
was very weird maybe it was just a
software bug
but both of these work great and eight
gigabytes of ram is not a limitation so
personally i would not spend extra money
to get a model that has a terabyte or
two terabyte of storage
if you want the extra ram keep in mind
apple is charging 200 bucks more
this year for the one terabyte option
than last year because of the extra ram
that they pair with it they don't give
you the option to have eight gigs
or 16 otherwise so i don't think it's
worth it and you also have to keep in
mind that
developers when new apps come out they
are going to optimize for 8 gigs of ram
not for 16 because most people are going
to buy the lower end units
so that is my opinion now if you guys
want to see more videos click that
circle above to help us reach 1 million
subscribers before the end of this year
and then right over there we have two
great ipad videos that you guys will
definitely enjoy
this has been max and i will see you in
the next video
you